so today let's talk about the worst keto
friendly low carb foods now when we talk
about keto friendly we're really talking
about low carb but just because
something is low-carb doesn't
necessarily mean it's healthy so let's
go down the list and we'll chat about
each one first one is soy protein
isolate it's one of the worst proteins
very low fat high concentrated protein
very damaging to the liver it's going to
be GMO okay so it's gonna have
glyphosate but I've had quite a few
people come in the office after
consuming this type of protein with a
lot of gallbladder and liver problems so
it's not a high quality protein it's
very very cheap it's in a lot of keto
friendly foods it's in a lot of those
breakfast bars and protein bars and even
in certain diets use this as their
protein mixture then we have casein this
is milk protein so first of all you're
rarely if ever gonna find a grass-fed
version of casein it's usually from cows
that consume grains that were GMO so on
the insulin index which are non
carbohydrate type foods like protein for
example this would be a lot higher
because when you have a low fat protein
it can spike insulin a lot more next
thing is Malta tall this is a sugar
alcohol that seems to create the most
digestive problems you see it in a lot
of sugar free candy sugar free chocolate
especially for diabetics but it's pretty
high on the glycemic index it's like 50
something next thing this aspartame you
know about that that interferes with
your gut flora there's been some studies
that show that it can increase insulin
resistance even though it's sugar-free
processed genes okay that you would get
at certain restaurants quite a few of
the cheeses that you see on the aisle of
the grocery store or processed not
healthy they come from milk and cows
that are not going to be grass-fed you
have to go to a healthy store to get
high quality cheese and the stuff that I
like is the grass-fed or
anok especially cheese from Europe next
seeing is the processed meats now
realize that pretty much all meats are
processed but I'm talking about the ones
that you'd get at the grocery store
which are common commercial processed
meats like the lunch meats hot dogs
bacon the deli meats the sausage from
animals that are factory farmed a lot of
preservatives nitrates you want to do
organic meats meats without hormones
grass fed rancid nuts let's say for
example you have some peanuts or walnuts
have been sitting in your cabinet for a
very long time
and when you consume them they're very
rancid not very healthy because the
omega-6 fatty acids which are very
unstable oxidized and you don't you
don't want to consume those next thing
is margarine
well it's keto friendly it's low carb
right when they did studies and epilepsy
for children one of the fats that they
used was margarine yeah it induces
ketosis but it's not very healthy and
just to point out the benefit of
lowering your carbs is huge because it's
gonna lower insulin and most people have
high insulin but why not take it to the
next level and use ingredients that are
quality iceberg lettuce I thing about
that is just basically it's empty
there's not much nutrition 1/2 of a cup
of kale equals 10 cups of iceberg
lettuce so you'd have to consume a
tremendous amount of it to get anything
at all and then you have doing what's
called dirty Quito where you're going to
a fast-food restaurant and you're
ordering the meat without the bun for
example well when you consume that meat
or the chicken it is low carb it's
protein but those animals are fed a lot
of GMO grains so you're not getting the
quality pork rinds now make sure you
don't get the version that has the msg
if you can get pork rinds without a
mystery it's a lot better but monosodium
glutamate has the ability to spike
insulin by 300% then we have vegetable
oils okay which are not really vegetable
oils they're seed oils an average
American will consume six and a half
liters or 11 pints of cooking oil per
person every single year
that's a lot of GMO oils I'm talking
about soy oil corn oil cottonseed oil
canola their GMO very inflammatory
there's some links to insulin resistance
and we're consuming tremendous amounts
versus in the past we consume a lot more
saturated fats now we switch to
unsaturated fats they're not healthier
but they're keto friendly okay then we
have corn fiber it could be non-gmo I
don't know but I have found that it does
create a lot of bloating in people so I
don't like this ingredient right here
and again I don't even know the quality
of corn that they use so it's kind of a
mystery and it's very hard to find out
the ingredients within this and how they
process it kind of a secret thing and
then we have farm-raised fish in factory
from meats the main thing is what they
feed these animals they're feeding them
GMO grains unfortunately and other
things for another video a lot of times
you're gonna see low fat dairy as being
in GML but of course it's not going to
be on the label so it's not non-gmo so
there's probably gonna be some
glyphosate which is herbicide in there
now the thing is that on the insulin
index the lower fat you go with the
protein the higher you spike insulin so
you don't want to do the low fat dairy
you don't want to do the egg whites you
want to do the whole egg you want to do
dairy with the whole milk just make sure
it's quality all right guys there's a
list and I'll see you in the next video
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos